lesbos auf der griechischen urlaubsinsel
wird ein neues flüchtlingslager gebaut
karatepe
4300 menschen auf einer dauerbaustelle
manos logothetis inspiziert den
fortschritt das griechische migrations
ministerium will vorbereitet sein auf
das was in den nächsten wochen droht
afghanistan hat 38 millionen einwohner
wenn nur zehn prozent unterwegs sind
dann kommen 3,8 millionen in unsere
richtung
wenn nur zehn prozent von denen über
griechenland kommen muss ich dem druck
standhalten können
familien untergebracht in zelten am
strand die hitze im sommer kaum
erträglich in den kommenden monaten soll
das camp zum vorzeigeprojekt der eu
werden mit beschleunigte asylverfahren
und schnellen rückführungen diesen plan
gibt es schon fünf jahre
im märz 2016 schließen eu türkei ein
abkommen europa versprach milliarden
hilfen im gegenzug verpflichtete sich
die türkei fluchtrouten abzuriegeln und
alle zurückzunehmen die aus sicht der
behörden nicht schutzbedürftig sind fest
steht seitdem wurden gerade einmal 2000
flüchtlinge von griechenland in die
türkei zurückgeschickt
das abkommen zeigte wirkung von einer
millionen menschen ging es runter auf
jährlich 100.000 neue künste aber diese
100.000 neue ankünfte bleiben in
griechenland wir tragen diese bürde
der grüne europa-abgeordnete erik
marquardt will sich ein bild über die
lebensbedingungen im camp machen vor
anderthalb jahren kam diese syrische
familie nach lesbos doch ihre chance auf
asyl in europa ist gering
in der befragung ging es kein einziges
mal um syrien sie haben immer nur nach
der türkei gefragt
obwohl die familie aus syrien aus einem
bürgerkriegsland kommt gilt die türkei
in ihrem asylverfahren als sicheres
herkunftsland eine ablehnung ist
wahrscheinlich
die frage auf wie es einem in syrien
angeht spielt in dem verfahren überhaupt
keine rolle mehr
und das soll ja nun auch mit menschen
aus afghanistan so gemacht werden
scheint mir aber so als wenn das
eigentlich der wunsch ist man möchte
dass die menschen nicht da sind aber als
sie verschwinden ja nicht einfach
die familie hofft weiter dass europa
ihnen asyl gewährt doch europa streitet
wie eine gerechte verteilung von
flüchtlingen aussehen soll seit 2005 10
wirkt die deutsche bundeskanzlerin dafür
dass jedes eu-land flüchtlinge aufnimmt
wir brauchen hier auch eine
kraftanstrengung der europäischen union
nur mit gemeinsamer europäischer
solidarität werden wir diesen kraftakt
meistern und wir sind ein europa der
werte
fünf jahre später an der litauischen
grenze zu belarus
2020 wurden hier 81 flüchtlinge
registriert in diesem jahr sind es mehr
als 4000 statt solidarische verteilung
abschottung
wir als europäische union stehen an der
seite von litauen um unsere gemeinsame
außengrenze zu beschützen
die eu innenkommissarin ylva johansson
zur lösungen präsentieren wie umgehen
wenn menschen an europas grenzen
asylbegehren
[Musik]
natürlich müssen wir solidarisch sein
mit menschen die angewiesen sind auf
internationalen schutz wir haben mit
140.000 menschen aber viel weniger
ankünfte und die mehrheit von ihnen sind
keine flüchtlinge
es sind menschen die eine bessere
zukunft wollen und dafür ihr leben
riskieren dafür brauchen wir wirklich
einen anderen ansatz
innenministerkonferenz in slowenien im
juli johansson präsentiert was sie für
eine solidarische flüchtlingspolitik
hält für abgelehnte migranten schlägt
sie sogenannte abschiebe patenschaften
vor mitgliedstaaten die keine menschen
aufnehmen wollen sollen die abschiebung
derer organisieren die kein asyl in
europa erhalten
wenn zb ungarn die abschiebung eines
afghanen der in deutschland lebt
übernimmt dann wird diese afghane aus
deutschland von ungarn organisiert nach
afghanistan zurück geführt wenn die
ungarn das nicht in die wege leiten muss
ungarn die person selber aufnehmen
und was wenn ungarn das nicht macht gibt
es irgendeine bestrafung
ich halte wenig davon für eine person zu
zahlen statt die verantwortung für einen
menschen zu übernehmen
ob solche sogenannten patenschaften
realistisch sind mehr als fraglich in
diesen tagen fliehen hunderttausende
menschen aus afghanistan
die grenze zu pakistan
europäische politiker fürchten eine neue
flüchtlingskrise staaten wie polen
ungarn und die slowakei haben in der
vergangenheit klar gemacht sie werden
keine flüchtlinge aufnehmen und auch die
bundeskanzlerin betonte am montagabend
dann müssen wir schauen dass sie eine
sichere
bleibe in der umgebung von afghanistan
haben und hier nicht den fehler
wiederholen den wir früher gemacht haben
und dass menschen sich dann auf den weg
gemacht haben aus jordanien aus libanon
aussehen direkt nach europa zu kommen
sondern dass wir hier heute schneller
sind und auch schnell den nachbarstaaten
hilfe anbieten wie viel hilfe europa
angesichts der kapitulation in
afghanistan leisten wird ist offen fest
steht deutschlands nachbarn setzen auf
eine politik der abschottung
wir versuchen ein neues asylsystem zu
etablieren wo die menschen nicht erst
nach dänemark kommen müssen sondern ihre
asylanträge außerhalb der europäischen
union stellen
wenn sie schutz brauchen bekommen sie
ihn außerhalb europas
der ansatz ist nicht neu in den
vergangenen jahren zogen zehntausende
durch die wüste richtung mittelmeer
deutschland und europa schlossen
abkommen mit afrikanischen staaten das
ziel die fluchtrouten kappen doch die
migration geht bis heute weiter
die idee des dänischen
migrationsminister in ländern wie
tunesien oder ägypten sollen asylzentren
unter europäischer kontrolle entstehen
dort soll entschieden werden wer asyl in
europa bekommt und wer nicht auch das
ist nicht neu dafür umstritten ob das
mit europäischen werten vereinbar ist
wie ihr gegangen wir entziehen uns auf
dänischer seite nicht unserer
verantwortung wir sind nicht dagegen
dass flüchtlinge nach dänemark kommen
aber es soll geordnet reguliert und über
die vereinten nationen erfolgen und
nicht durch menschenschmuggel
zurück auf lesbos der griechischen
urlaubsinsel
noch einmal unterwegs mit dem grünen
europaabgeordneten erik marquardt es
türmen sich die überbleibsel der
flüchtlingskrise von 2015
ich glaube es ist einfach eine illusion
dass wir sagen europäische asylpolitik
kann man auslagern andere staaten dass
wir eigentlich gar keine solidarität in
europa mehr brauchen für mich ist es ein
symbol des scheiterns dass man die ganze
zeit versucht verantwortung
wegzuschieben
im sommer
2021 haben europas politiker angst vor
der nächsten flüchtlingskrise und keine
antwort auf die frage was tun wenn
wieder zig tausende in boote steigen